what is up everybody I am so excited to
hop into this year I am ready and I am
back because we got something special
for y'all 3D artists young and old the
time is upon us to push the limit of our
creativity to raise the bar together as
a passionate community of artists and
create something larger than our
individual selves that is right it is
time for another 3D Community challenge
I am proud to announce endless engines
our first ever 3D vehicle challenge so
starting today starting right now I
challenge you to buckle up and create
the coolest sports car the coolest truck
the coolest tractor trailer bike boat
biplane or whatever gets you excited and
populate this template scene with your
unique creation so we can create the
coolest Convoy of 3D Vehicles the
internet has ever dreamed of and as we
do I will hand pick the top 100
submissions to be featured in their own
epic montage complete with an original
soundtrack by none other thing composer
Casey Edwards himself and on March 18th
be a live stream I'll be joined by my
very good friends Peter France Ren
weichmann and the one the
the only
Captain dissolution
or is it his intern regardless we're
going to reveal the top 100 renders to
the world and Crown five hard-working
artists as the endless engines winners
but what do you win now I always try to
bring my favorite companies together for
these challenges to get you guys
top-notch Tech I hand pick each prize
and stand by each and every product in
this prize pool as I personally use them
myself it's also important that everyone
has access to these prizes so we're
fortunate enough to have another
International prize pool this time
around so our fourth and fifth place
artists are getting three things first
off you're winning three World building
kits from our friends at kit bash 3D
they boast a massive selection of high
quality kits to choose from and you get
to pick any three you like each kit
comes with a ton of optimized assets to
make World building a blast and they
support nearly every software and render
engine combo but if you want to pick up
a kit or two for your submission this
month use that code in the description
to get 20 off through March 4th only so
on top of the kit bash 3D kits I
partnered with a Turkish design brand
called caft so caft is throwing you guys
200 toward anything on their site their
shirts are legit their hoodies are legit
their jackets joggers beanies socks bags
they're all legit their designs are sick
super minimal very unique and the
Turkish textiles are some of the best in
the world and finally on top of the
three kit bash 3D kits and the 200 caft
prize my longtime friends at Maxon are
giving you guys a full year of Maxon one
which of course includes Cinema 4D the
program I'll be using to create my
submission for this challenge but for
the people who use different programs
Maxon one also comes with the redshift
render engine the entire red giant
post-production suite zbrush for your 3D
sculpting needs as well as forger when
you want to use your iPhone or iPad to
sculpt on the go and that is just fourth
and fifth Place y'all so for the artist
who slides into that third place spot on
top of the Maxon one gear subscription
the 200 caft prize and your choice of
three kid bash 3D kits the good people
at Rococo are up in the ante yet again
and hooking you up with a pair of their
Rococo smart gloves making hand and
finger animation an absolute Breeze you
don't need a suit to get creative with
these bad boys they go for about six
hours on a single charge and can record
up to 100 frames per second now I just
want to mention I don't know if you all
realize this but Rococo did drop a free
no suit needed motion capture solution
it's called Rococo video and it's a game
changer not only is it free but you just
need to upload a clip of you doing your
thing or record it with a webcam and you
can process and export in minutes and to
celebrate the launch for Coco's actually
raffling away a free pair of smart
gloves this month to anyone who
processes a motion capture clip I've got
a link for you in the description below
get yourself some free mocap data and if
your renderer comes in second place
you're of course getting the three kit
bash 3D kits of choice the 200 capped
prize the Max on one subscription and
again from our friends at Rococo a smart
suit Pro 2 motion capture suit to make
character animation even easier their
smartsoup Pro 2 is a lot more accurate
it reads shock to the suit a lot better
and it supports elevation change and
look if your render comes out on top as
the greatest render of all time then you
are winning the three kit bash 3D kits
the 200 kaft prize the Maxon one
subscription and on behalf of Maxon and
Camp mograph we're flying you out to
join myself and other 3D artists at Camp
mograph it's a no technology multi-day
3D Meetup where we all learn laugh and
grow together through intimate creative
classes Fireside Chats outdoor
activities and most importantly
chill time but that's not all you're
also getting a full performance capture
bundle from the beautiful people at
Rococo complete with the smartsoup Pro 2
of course a pair of smart gloves facial
caption support and a body mount to
capture those beautiful Expressions this
list gets longer and longer every time
we do this and I'm honestly not even
done because it's getting even crazier
the top 100 are getting a kit bash kit
of their choice between their five new
kits here and caft is also stepping up
to give a free t-shirt code to all of
the top 100 as well my goodness what a
list I hope you guys are as pumped as I
am I Gotta Give a huge shout out to caft
Kit bash3d Camp mograph Maxon and Rococo
for continually supporting these
challenges with their gear and
incentivizing y'all to keep stepping up
each and every time we do these things
so to get started you'll just want to
download the starter files linked below
inside you're gonna find a few helpful
resources but most importantly the
project files for your program of choice
where we've set up a basic template for
you to start creating the rules this
time are pretty simple you have the next
five weeks to replace this demo scene
with your own unique creation just make
sure you don't mess with the camera
angle keep your vehicle generally Center
framed once it enters and maintain the
consistent sense of movement to the
right hey but what about frame rate file
type resolution actually does my vehicle
need
[Music]
cover all those questions and more on my
Discord server linked below it's where
I'll be posting updates announcements
even doing live Q as with you guys every
Monday it's not a requirement but my
Discord server has always acted as our
main day-to-day support network for
these 3D challenges it's free of course
so hop in if you can I promise it'll be
very helpful to you guys yeah but when
is that deadline I've been waiting for
that deadline that deadline is Sunday
March 12th at 11 59 Pacific Standard
time I got my whole challenge schedule
for y'all right here all the way through
April so mark them calendars I want to
make this as easy as possible on you
guys so I'm live streaming an hour after
this video goes live chances are I'm
already streaming so hop in and let's
brainstorm some ideas together and get
them brain juices flowing and the last
thing I want to mention for you guys I'm
a sucker for stickers all right since I
was a kid I couldn't get enough stickers
so I thought
wouldn't it be sweet to do a limited
edition run of high quality vinyl
stickers specific to the endless engines
3D challenge it's a great way to collect
some challenge swag and of course an
awesome way to support more challenges
like this in the future now once these
guys sell out that is it alright no
restocks on these so grab one while you
can at my print store noisegreen and
light.com I got a link for you guys in
the description below and I want to
encourage anyone whether you're new to
3D or a long time practitioner to just
hop in and have fun to see what we can
all do together because at the end of
the day that's what this is all about so
download them files hop in on the
Discord start your dang engines and
let's get it I'll see you on the live
stream peace
[Music]
thank you